Stephen hawking soll kurz vor seinem tod noch ein geniestreich gelungen seien der beweis von paralleluniversum der beweis der existenz eines
Multiversums einer welt von der universum das wäre wirklich eine unglaubliche situation es gibt nämlich zahlreiche modelle hypothesen und theorien über die
existenz von parallel universen aber keine einzige davon
Konnte auch nur im ansatz
Bewiesen werden das könnte jetzt auf einen schlag anders werden und stephen hawking würde auf einen schlag in die absolut erste reihe der physiker aufsteigen
Was ist also mit dem multiversum auf sich hat und was stephen hawking bewiesen hat jetzt den krieg zum science fiction
Das wäre wirklich eine absolute hammer stephen hawking würde seinem lebenswerk die krone aufsetzen und die physik. Welt umkrempeln eine
Welt aus parallel universen ein multiversum aber
Was könnte er bewiesen haben für ein multiversum gibt es verschiedene ansätze der eine ansatz ist der der heisenbergsche unschärferelation
Wellen neben ja erst ihre teilchen eigenschaften an wenn sie beobachtet wenn sie gemessen werden spricht werden sie nicht beobachtet gibt es
Wahrscheinlichkeiten mit dem sie an bestimmten orten existieren sie existieren aber nicht dort man könnte auch sagen dass sie nicht
existieren da ja nicht festgestellt werden kann
Wo sie sind oder in welchem zustand sie sind bundes beispiel das doppel spalt experiment lasse
Ich nicht durch einen doppel spalt fallen bildet es als projektion ein interferenzmuster
Messe ich aber durch welchen spalt welches lichtzeichen fliegt ändert das licht seine eigenschaft von einem interferenzmuster
verursachten welle teilchen das interferenzmuster
Verschwindet die beiden spalte werden jetzt projiziert oder schuldiger das berühmte katze lasse ich eine katze sterben wenn ein
bestimmtes teilchen zerfällt dann stürzt sie nicht bzw
sie stirbt oder sich stirbt eben auch nicht und zwar erst wenn wir den zustand des teilchens messen vorher gab es nur eine wahrscheinlichkeit
Des verfalls und das ist tatsächlich so die katze war damit auch nur mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit
tot oder lebendig total verrückt daher stammt aber die theorie dass sich die welt erst in dem moment
manifestiert in der wir sie messen oder beobachten vorher sind es nur wellen und wahrscheinlichkeiten wir würden dann jeweils durch messen und beobachten immer wieder
neue
universen entstehen lassen das ist komplett verrückt wirklich ein anderer ansatz wäre die stringtheorie
Sie besagt dass alles nur wählen sind also sehr ähnlich eine meiner lieblings theorien alles besteht aus einen
dimensionalen fäden linien die in einer bestimmten frequenz oder einem bestimmten frequenzbereich
schwingen bei licht können wir das ja ganz gut nachvollziehen demnach nach dieser theorie gibt es noch zahlreiche weitere dimensionen und in diesen dimensionen
existieren dann parallel universum und sie können sogar miteinander kollidieren über eine spur einer solchen kollision hatte ich ja hier letztlich
Berichtet alles in allem ist aber keine der theorien bewiesen das sind letztlich, im gegensatz zum bewies klimawandel oder der zweifelsfrei bewiesen
evolutionstheorie nur denkmodelle oder
gedankenexperimente wenn man allerdings diese modelle oder eines dieser modelle mit einem mathematischen
Konstrukt beschreiben kann und dann noch einen beweis daraus herleiten kann dann wird es eine theorie die bewiesen ist
allerdings dürfen das dann nicht nur entwickler dieser theorie und dieses beweises machen sondern auch andere wissenschaftler müssen in der lage sein
Das durchzurechnen und zu beweisen dann wird eine solche theorie zur bewiesene theorie und wir haben eine
wirkliche erkenntnisse gewonnen hawking hat für viele grundlegende phänomene wie schwarze löcher den urknall den ereignishorizont von schwarzen löchern
Das schon oft getan und jetzt kommt vielleicht sein meisterwerk gemeinsam mit dem belgischen physiker thomas hartung hat er eine
multiversum theorie entwickelt den beiden physikern sollte es tatsächlich gelungen sein eine
mathematische grundlage für das multiversum entwickelt
Zu haben sonst wird die arbeit eben peer review verfahren gecheckt kommen die
Wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler zu dem ergebnis dass die arbeit korrekt ist wäre damit eine
wissenschaftliche bombe geplatzt ist wäre bewiesen dass wir in einem parallel universum leben das nächste ziel
Wäre zu erkunden wie wir solche parallel universen beobachten können oder spuren von ihnen finden können wenn ihr kein video zu diesem thema zum thema
paralleluniversum und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollten dann endet meine telefonnummer bei whatsapp das geht ganz einfach mit diesem link dann
informiere ich über meinen neuesten videos vor allen anderen und das garantiert anders als sie auf youtube dort könnte ja auch bei klick zum mitmachen
Und mit themen vorschlagen oder bei abstimmung mitmachen und damit beeinflussen was sie auf klicks und passiert vergessen natürlich nicht das abo
und den klick auf die genau locker und hier geht es weiter dafür auch draufklicken zusammenstoß mit einem paralleluniversum
Ja das ist ein spannendes thema an sonst würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran